Power is shifting.
History has taught us
that technology will take power
from the establishment,
and give it to individuals.
Give it to people.
This has been true since
before the advent of the printing press.
Long before.
But the path is not a straight line,
there are always bumps
and detours along the way,
and the internet is no exception.
The original promise of the internet
was to push power
down into the hands of people,
and to all of us.
And it has.
It has weakened yesterday's gatekeepers,
music labels, news
publications, TV networks.
They've all lost much
of their power and prestige.
But at the same time,
the internet has created
a new establishment.
It's pushed power
into the broadest of platforms,
like Instagram.
This was unexpected.
But I believe that,
over the broad arc of history,
that this unexpected outcome,
this concentration of power in the hands
of a handful of platforms,
is not going to be a long-lasting trend.
Over the next ten years,
we're going to see
a dramatic shift in power,
away from platforms like the one
that my team and I are responsible for,
and to a group of people
I like to describe as "creators."
Let's define a creator
as someone whose personality
is their brand,
and who uses platforms like Instagram
to turn their passion into a living.
Creators like Blair Imani,
D-Nice and Benny Drama.
They generate new ideas,
push boundaries, drive culture.
We follow them just to see
what they'll do next.
What if we imagine a world where creators
actually own their relationship
with their audience --
they didn't rent it, they owned it --
and where all of us were invested
in their success?
A world where the platforms
acted more like platforms,
because we can and should do more
to support creators.
It's been maybe 50 years
since the birth of the internet,
and we can all see
how much it has affected
almost every industry,
particularly the attention-based
industries: music, news, TV, art --
they've all been disrupted.
Musicians like Childish Gambino,
Frank Ocean and Chance the Rapper,
they found ways to reach
an audience without a label.
When Jessica Yellin was the chief
White House correspondent for CNN,
back in 2012,
that network averaged
about 670,000 viewers.
Today, she reaches nearly that many
people on Instagram alone.
Star athletes are more relevant
than the teams that they play for,
which would have been
unheard of 50 years ago.
LeBron James has more
followers on Instagram
than the Lakers do.
Cristiano Ronaldo makes more
on Instagram, it's been reported,
than he did from Juventus.
OK, so I and my team,
we work at the point
where creators and audiences meet.
And platforms like Instagram
have done a lot to empower creators
over the last ten years.
My team is obsessed with finding
more ways to support creators.
But if we accept that as power
continues to shift toward creators,
or that that's going to happen,
because technology
will continue to change,
then we're going to have
to rethink some things,
because today, creators
are too dependent on too few platforms,
then our role, as platforms,
has to change.
Now, I'm not saying
that platforms are going to go away.
New platforms will certainly rise,
old platforms will certainly fall.
But all platforms will --
and you're already seeing this happen --
understand the value that creators create.
And so they'll be increasingly interested
in handing more power over to creators.
Now, this might be surprising,
coming from me.
But I think this is actually
a really good thing.
I think that over the long run,
what's best for creators
is going to be best for platforms
like the one I'm responsible for.
The more art there is,
the more there's an exchange of ideas,
the more creativity there is in the world,
the better off we all are.
But we haven't always seen
the world this way.
For the five years
before I joined Instagram,
I was the head of News Feed at Facebook.
I was in that role during
the US presidential election in 2016.
I was in that role
during Cambridge Analytica.
I traveled around the world,
talking to publishers and policymakers,
most of whom took the time to tell me
everything that we were doing wrong.
I'm sure some of you
hold my company and me
personally accountable
for all sorts of things.
But I can tell you
we learned an immense amount
from those experiences.
I know I personally did.
There were a lot of lessons.
And one of those lessons
was how important
stability and predictability
were to publishers.
No publisher can build a business
on a platform that's too volatile,
and no business should be entirely reliant
on any one platform.
The same is true for creators.
Today ...
Whoo.
We’re on the precipice
of an entirely new internet,
built on fundamentally different
technology than the tools of yesterday.
New technology
is making new ideas possible.
Cryptocurrencies, social tokens,
nonfungible tokens,
decentralized autonomous organizations --
that one really rolls off the tongue --
smart contracts --
these are a group of ideas
known in the industry as web3.
And each and every one is built
on a foundation called the blockchain.
The important thing to understand
about blockchains
is that they remove the need
for an intermediary.
What do I mean by that?
Well, each and every one of you,
I am sure, at some point,
has put money in a bank account.
And when you did that,
you were actually trusting
an intermediary --
in this case, a bank --
to take care of that money on your behalf.
A blockchain allows you
to hold digital money --
in this case, a cryptocurrency --
without the need to trust
an intermediary or a bank.
And so a blockchain offers the potential
for a transfer of power.
What's interesting
is not holding digital money --
there's nothing new about that idea.
What is interesting
is how power is shifting
from those who historically held it
to those who have not.
There's an opportunity here.
We can use this technology
to help creators establish
direct financial relationships
with their audience,
independent of any platform.
Today, for many
creators -- not all, but many --
subscriptions are an important part
of their business.
And there are really great
subscription platforms out there --
Patreon, Substack, YouTube memberships.
They provide great services.
For you, as a creator,
they host your content,
they distribute that content,
they handle payments on your behalf.
What does it cost you?
You're beholden to each platform
where you show up.
You are playing by that platform's rules.
So what if we imagine something different?
A subscription between a creator
and a fan, still,
but one independent of any platform,
but that works across all platforms.
On a five-year time view,
the blockchain offers the opportunity
for creators to directly own
their relationship with their subscribers.
Picture this.
Lisa is a country artist from Georgia,
and she wants to sell subscriptions.
Maybe she wants to share songs
that she's working on
before she's ready to release them
to the general public.
And we all love Lisa,
and we want to subscribe to Lisa.
What if Lisa can sell a token --
think of it as a membership card --
for a few bucks,
to anyone who wants to subscribe.
What if every major platform --
Instagram, Twitter, YouTube, Facebook,
they all agree to honor
those membership cards.
Then, in that world, if Lisa
first establishes herself on Instagram,
but later, she wants
to branch out into Twitter,
she can bring Team Lisa with her,
she can bring her subscribers with her.
And all of us,
because I’m sure we love Lisa,
we only need to subscribe once,
not once per platform.
That' a big deal.
And even more important,
if we build these membership cards
on a blockchain,
no company can ever take
Lisa's community away from her.
Instagram could -- poof! --
disappear tomorrow
and she would maintain her relationship
with her subscribers,
and she would maintain her income.
We can take this idea further.
As we look to the future,
it's increasingly clear that it's going
to bring more and more volatility,
as technology changes
more and more quickly.
For creators, this means
new talent can succeed
faster than ever before,
and at an incredible scale.
It also means that we will never again see
the stability in careers
that our grandparents saw.
There's a problem.
One challenge with this future
is that our financial infrastructure,
particularly the way
that we finance our ideas,
largely predates the internet.
Today, the predominant way
that businesses raise money,
and the only real option
available to creators,
is to borrow it as debt.
And as to any of you
who have ever struggled
with a mortgage payment
or a student loan or a car payment
can attest to,
there’s a lot of downside to debt.
My first experience with debt
was a 13-year old '86 SAAB 9000 Turbo.
Gray car, saggy roof,
the Knight Rider lights
in the front -- I love that car.
But it was hard.
So what if, instead of debt,
we invested in people,
the way we invest in start-ups?
As a creator, you should be able
to use technology
to raise money to finance your ambitions.
If you so choose,
you should be able to sell
equity in your future.
And you should be able to set the terms.
For a 100,000-dollar investment,
you’ll pay out five percent
of what you make for the next 10 years.
And we can codify those terms
in a smart contract.
We can connect the RevShare
you make on YouTube,
the subscription fees you make on Patreon,
the merchandise sales
you make on Instagram,
all to one token that anyone
who believes in you could buy.
And in doing so,
you'd be giving your audience
the opportunity to share in your success,
to buy a share,
to build equity in the creator
they know, love and trust.
And Lisa would be able to build
a community of people
who are directly invested in her success.
And with the money she raised,
she'd have more time to explore,
more time to create.
Meta can't build this.
No single company can.
For ideas like these to happen,
we need to come together
across the industry.
And we need pioneers.
We need established creators
to prove the model at first.
But the idea isn't interesting
until it's available to everyone.
I sometimes think about what my path
might have looked like,
had that opportunity been available to me.
Instead of bartending
and designing websites on the side
and taking out a lot of student debt,
I might have sold equity in my future.
What might you have done?
Who knows?
But what's exciting about this idea
is not the opportunity it affords
an upper-middle-class white kid
from the suburbs of New York City.
It's the opportunity
it affords Oumi Janta,
a roller-skating phenom in Berlin;
Terri Loewenthal, one of my favorite
photographers in California.
And if we build this,
we'll have helped to realize
the original promise of the internet.
We'll have to push power
into the hands of people ...
to creators.
Creators will be able to own
their relationship with their audience,
and anyone who wants
to invest in creativity
will have the opportunity to do so.
We'll have created a world
where anyone with a compelling idea
can turn their passion into a living,
which, at the same time, effects
possibly the greatest transfer of power
from institutions to individuals
in all of history.
Thank you for listening,
and thank you to you creators out there
for inspiring the rest of us.
(Applause)